20 signs that you are emotionally mature
you realize that most of the bad
behavior of other people really comes
down to fear and anxiety rather than as
it's generally easier to presume
nastiness or idiocy you loosen your hold
on self-righteousness and stop thinking
of the world as populated by either
monsters or fools
it makes things less black and white at
first but in time a great deal more
interesting you learn that what's in
your head can't automatically be
understood by other people you realize
that unfortunately you're going to have
to articulate your intentions and
feelings with the use of words and can't
fairly blame other people for not
getting what you mean until you've
spoken calmly and clearly you learn that
remarkably you do sometimes get things
wrong with huge courage you take your
first faltering steps towards once in a
while apologizing you learn to be
confident not by realizing that you're
great but by learning that everyone else
is just a stupid scared and lost as you
are we're all making it up as we go
along and that's fine you forgive your
parents because you realize that they
didn't put you on this earth in order to
insult you
they were just painfully out of their
depth and struggling with demons of
their own anger turns at points to pity
and compassion you learn the enormous
influence of so-called small things on
mood bedtimes blood sugar and alcohol
levels degrees of background stress and
so on and as a result you learn never to
bring up an important contentious issue
with a loved one until everyone is well
rested no one is drunk you've had some
food nothing else is alarming you and
you're not rushing to catch a train you
give up sulking if someone hurts you you
don't store up the hatred and the hurt
for days you
remember we'll all be dead soon you
don't expect others to know what's wrong
you tell them straight and if they get
it you forgive them and if they don't in
a different way you forgive them too you
cease to believe in perfection in pretty
much every area there aren't any perfect
people
perfect jobs or perfect lives instead
you pivot towards an appreciation of
what is to use the psychoanalyst Donald
Winnicott exemplary phrase good enough
you realize that many things in your
life are at once quite frustrating and
yet in many ways eminently good enough
you learn the virtues of being a little
more pessimistic about how things will
turn out and as a result emerge as a
karma more patient and more forgiving
soul you lose some of your idealism and
become a far less maddening person you
learn to see that everyone's weaknesses
of character are linked to
counterbalancing strengths rather than
isolating their weaknesses you look at
the whole picture
yes someone is rather pedantic but
they're also beautifully precise and a
rock at times of turmoil yes someone is
a bit messy but at the same time
brilliantly creative and very visionary
you realize truly realize that perfect
people don't exist and that every
strengths will be tagged to a weakness
you fall in love a bit less easily it's
difficult in a way when you were less
mature you could develop a crush in an
instant now your poignant Lee aware that
everyone however externally charming or
accomplished would be a bit of a pain
from close up you develop loyalty to
what you already have you learn that you
are rather surprisingly quite a
difficult person to live with you shared
some of your earlier sentimentality
towards yourself you go into friendships
and relationships offering others kindly
warnings of how and when you might prove
a challenge you learn to forgive
yourself for your errors and foolishness
you
the unfruitful self-absorption involved
in simply flogging yourself for past
mistakes you become more of a friend to
yourself
of course you're an idiot but you're
still a lovable one as we all are you
learn that part of what maturity
involves is making peace with a
stubbornly childlike bits of you that
will always remain you cease trying to
be a grown-up at every occasion you
accept that we all have our regressive
moments and when the inner two-year-old
you raises its head you greet them
generously and give them the attention
they need you cease to put too much hope
in grand plans for the kind of happiness
you expect could last for years
you start to celebrate the little things
that go well you realize that
satisfaction comes in increments of
minutes you're delighted if one day
passes by without too much bother you
take a greater interest in flowers and
in the evening sky you develop a taste
for small pleasures what people in
general think of you ceases to be such a
concern you realize that the minds of
others are muddled places and you don't
try so hard to polish your image in
everyone else's eyes what counts is that
you and one or two others are ok with
you being you you give up on Fame and
start to rely on love you get better at
hearing feedback rather than assuming
that anyone who criticizes you is either
trying to humiliate you or is making a
mistake you accept that maybe it would
be an idea to take a few things on board
you start to see that you can listen to
a criticism and survive it without
having to put on your armor and deny
that there was ever a problem you
realize the extent to which you tend to
live day by day in to greater proximity
to certain of your problems and issues
you remember more and more that you need
to get out and get a perspective on the
things that pain you you take more walks
in nature you might get a pet they don't
fret like we do and you appreciate
to the distant galaxies above us in the
night sky you recognize how your
distinctive past colors your response to
events and learn to compensate for the
distortions that can result you accept
that because of how your childhood went
you have a predisposition to exaggerate
in certain areas you become suspicious
of your own first impulses around
particular topics you realize sometimes
not to go with your first feelings when
you start a friendship you realize that
other people don't principally want to
know your good news so much has gained
an insight into what troubles and
worries you so that they can in turn
feel less lonely with the pains of their
own hearts you become a better friend
because you see that what friendship is
really about is a sharing of
vulnerability
our emotional barometer is a tool that
can help us to more clearly explain our
moods click the link on screen now to
find out more
you